[Applaudissements]
première
les premières élections municipales le
débat bienvenue dans un nouveau des bars
des élections municipales et
communautaires 2020 sur l'antenne radio
et le site web de martinique la première
un débat donc de campagne électorale
dédiée cette fois à la ville de saint
pierre avec nous deux candidates à
savoir ludmilla la raddho stache bonsoir
madame également et vianne sesto bonsoir
madame est un candidat colistiers du
maire sortant en l'occurrence hervé
planchette
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes adjoint
adjoint au maire christian afa puisqu'il
ne peut pas se rendre n'a pas pu se
rendre disponible pour ce rendez vous
pour ce débat le maire christian rafah
merci à vous trois d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et sans plus tarder jean-marc
parti qui anime le débat aussi nous
présente ce soir la ville d'art et
d'histoire
la seule me semble-t-il en martinique
avoir ce label oui peut être pour
l'instant même si saint pierre 1 peuvent
paraître un enfant aux visiteurs ouais
même ceux qui vivent les pyrrhotine et
les pierrotin la belle endormie au pied
de la montagne pelée une ville plutôt
tranquille où il n'y a pas une agitation
formidable il simplement que peut-être
d'animation c'est vraiment avec une
particularité c'est que c'est l'une des
rares villes lyon ben alors ça fait un
peu plus au nazisme mais en fait saint
pierre d'aujourd'hui est l'héritière de
saint-pierre d'avant la catastrophe
peuplée d'environ 30000 habitants
je parle lui de la catastrophe de 1902
est une ville qui a gardé après sa
réhabilitation sont 41 ans et aux bas
salaires avec des maisons des immeubles
des rues très très importantes et
notamment les deux roues qui traverse à
saint pierre du sida ou du nord au sud
de la rue victor hugo dans le sens
sud-nord donc en gros entre tarbes et de
direction de son temps du quart mais
pour aller vers le prêcheur et dans
l'autre sens laroui bouyer ce sont donc
ceux qui donnent à saint pierre un
cachet particulier on a l'impression
qu'elle s'étend sur comme ça quasiment 3
km alors que il y en a ri en pays qu'on
ne connaît pas forcément et puis des
quartiers périphériques le mouillage
lefort la galère et c'est bien que situé
géographiquement pour ceux qui l'ont
bien
qui n'y vont pas très souvent au bord
d'une magnifique robe à la rade de saint
pierre l'une des plus belles n'ont pas
de martinique mais de la caraïbe bon
soyons chauvins on peut venir en paix
rue à saint-pierre sa part le prochain
en passant par fonds canaux ville sainte
philomène ou la galère on peut en venir
depuis mon nom rouge en passant par
trois ponts depuis français denis
également et enfin depuis le cas en b
après lens la touche et le trou ses
pieds en ces temps ci vend environ 3860
12 hectares elle est peu plus
aujourd'hui un peu plus de 4100
habitants c'est une commune comme
beaucoup d'autres qui paie en population
4300 personnes en 2010 donc ça veut dire
que là aussi la décrue démographique se
fait sentir
la commune est représentée par deux
délégués à cap nau l'intercommunalité
sous les 50 membres de son conseil
communautaire et les électrices et les
électeurs devront choisir dans quelques
semaines 29 conseillers municipaux
je ne reviens pas sur l'histoire de
saint piat très riche sauf pour dire que
les 27 conseillers municipaux merci
monsieur planchette sauf qu'elle est
c'est la plus ancienne commune de la
technique c'est le premier foyer de la
colonisation de 735 septembre 1635 et
qui a été radié on le rappelle de la
liste des communes de france après sa
destruction en mai 1910 par la
catastrophe de l'appeler avant d'être
réhabilité en 1923 elle vit
essentiellement du tourisme et de
l'exploitation à ciel ouvert des
carrières de pouzzolane qui entre dans
la fabrication du ciment et du béton
merci jean marc peut-être que
quelquefois y aller faut y aller vous en
voudront savoir a dit que la bête saint
pierre est la plus belle de la caraïbe
peut-être avec celle de fort-de-france
aussi bon enfin voilà allez pour
commencer nous vous proposons en hors
d'oeuvre pour ainsi dire le traditionnel
micro trottoir réalisé par christine
cuppitt auprès de quelques habitants
pierrotin rencontrés ici ou là ce matin
même nous écoutons et vous réagirez
ensuite effectivement g
nous avons donc en principe ce micro
trottoir réalisé par christine cuppitt
que nous devrions pouvoir retrouver
c'est vrai que nous avons quelque peu
surpris notre technicien nous nous en
excusons s'éteint alors le temps qui
nous retrouvent eux cela ou alors on va
commencer et puis on nous on le mettra
peut-être un peu plus tard dans la
présentation des candidats mais oui oui
alors ben commence et jean-marc on
représente les candidats le temps qu'on
trouve cet élément voilà alors par andré
alphabétique
c'est le plus simple tout d'abord nous
avons madame eliane sesto qui est bien
connu des habitants et des habitants de
saint pierre madame c'est ce taux qui
est fraîchement retraité vous avez était
fonctionnaire au ministère des finances
et vous êtes à la tête de la liste
génération saint pierre bertrand
oui alors l'autre candidat donc ludmilla
cc vous convient de présenter madame c
voilà alors le jeu excusez moi je ne
vais pas les techniciens de parler
ludmila lara d'eustache aux est âgé de
53 ans est agent de 52 ans vous êtes
agent de collectivité
vous êtes de la liste agissons pour
saint pierre vous êtes déjà conseillère
municipale d'opposition et vous avez été
maire adjointe de raphaël martin entre
2008 et 2015 c'est bien sûr voilà et à
faire le dernier candidat tête de liste
christian la fin j'ai de 65 ans
pharmacien biologiste de son métier
fraîchement retraité qui à la tête de la
liste fait fait en gagner saint pierre
c'est le maire sortant élu en mars 2015
après l'annulation du scrutin de mars
2014 mais comme disait bertrand cariou
tout à l'heure il n'a pas pu être
disponible ce soir il est représenté ici
par l'un de ces colistiers en la
personne de monsieur hervé planchette
que nous remercions
voilà donc merci beaucoup à eddy le
curieux clerville qui a fait une petite
prouesse et donc il nous a retrouvé ce
micro trottoir que christine cupide donc
à réaliser aujourd'hui à saint pierre
c'est pierre deviennent villefranque
temps vous à dire que les habitants de
saint pierre sont logés en périphérie
vous avez une ville avec des immeubles
vides et les en fait des cités en
périphérie alors ça fait que dès que le
soleil se couche mais y'a personne dans
saint piat puisque les gens sont en
périphérie à rien
ehpad à l'ex-sportif il n'y a pas de
centre culturel il y avait beaucoup plus
de choses avancent que maintenant et à
plus de sport + de kermesse plus
d'associations les clubs sportifs et a
pas de date précise n'a rien il ya du
tourisme et la nouvelle médiation du
système c'est bon maintenant tout le
monde où un bus et puis tout le monde
les emmène feront à saint-pierre et puis
par l'omi peau voilà il est papa
les jeunes c'est à faire des jobs
saint-pierre normal sympathie comme enki
bien c'est un grand combine messari nice
et qu'elle aime ou non pouvoir il part à
respecter les engagements cailloux prend
ni débat qui fait prendre aux
populations notamment musée à l'ania
sachant qu'il fait nous passons dans ces
conditions et puis on a un goût de
problèmes à saint pierre c'est qu'on a
des carrières la ville et traversé toute
la journée par des camions sans arrêt
qui abîment les routes les trottoirs
nous avons de la poussière du bruit et
cetera il a ces terriens saint pierre il
faut que travail se tient et on a des
embouteillages 3 ko du temps on a
d'autres qu'on appelle la mer des
antilles on pourrait mettre une bâche et
expédié ce matériau au centre de la
martinique ça éviterait que les gens
traversent la ville tous ces matériaux
vu son action du volcan pourquoi ne pas
à donner une taxation taxer ce qui sort
de sa carrière peut-être que d'autres y
ont pensé on verra peut-être que ça ça
ce sera une de vos propositions
alors on rappelle que ça n'a pas valeur
de sondage que ce n'est pas non plus un
échantillon représentatif de toute la
population pyrrhotine ce sont des
habitants et des habitantes que
christine cupidon qu'a rencontrés au gré
de ses pérégrinations dans la commune ci
ou là au hasard donc il leur a demandé
leur avis donc voilà qui souhaitent
réagir en premier avant que nous posions
notre première question il vient de
sesto je vous vois je trouve que l'un
dire pratique assez dur là-dessus mais
elle a entièrement raison parce que moi
j'habite dans le centre-ville et
croyez moi la plus grande le plus grand
problème c'est cette circulation et
cette circulation ça a un impact sur
tout le reste
nous avons aussi c'est vrai que nous
avons les infrastructures qui sont qu'à
vieillissante
elles sont même vieillissante et délabré
donc je pense que mais c'est un peu
panneaux mettent à la population dans
des choses qui ne le sont pas d'accord
mais c'est pas des faits récents
forcément ça fait un moment que ça
caractérise la ville oui mais parce que
bon il faudrait dire que si nous sommes
dans cet état ça veut dire que plusieurs
mandatures n'ont pas entretenu la
réponse est alors je voudrais bien ce
que dit madame c est où elle a dit que
plusieurs montagnes ou non prendre
retenue mais plus une mandature le 4 on
ne peut pas résoudre ce qui est épars
cap été fait pendant plus de 14 ans 4
ans vous dites cinq ans on aura 54 ans
répond le 7 avril monsieur famille donc
sauvegarder soirée car oui pardon voyons
si quelques mois et donc à moi non je
sais mais on ne pouvait pas non plus il
faut rester réaliste on ne pouvait pas
changer les choses c'est plus facile de
détruire que de construire et donc nous
sommes dans une phase de construction
avec un déficit de cumulé de 3,4
millions d'euros contre son mari vais
donc avec une baguette magique on
n'aurait pas pu le faire non plus nous
attendons la population
nous écoutons nous essayons de prioriser
les actions tout en tenant compte de la
réglementation aussi parce que les gens
pensent aussi que nous pourrons faire
n'importe quoi que le mairie a tout
pouvoir
c'est que ça se passe pas comme ça on
oublie donc il faut effectivement
prendre le temps de et c'est pour ça que
nous sommes d'ailleurs candidat à une
seconde nature pour terminer le travail
que nous avons commencé
ludmila la radio stage pour terminer
donc que ce tour de table et puis vous
répondrai ensuite à la première question
que jean-marc partie posera alors je
suis ravi de ce micro trottoir
je vois que ma population elle et elle
est bien noël et bien éveillée et elle
voit tout ce qu'elle voit effectivement
où l'équipe actuelle a failli manque
d'apps d'apps manque de politique
sociale manque de politique
environnementale manque de politique
sportive culturelle
tout est dit dans ce micro trottoir et
quand j'entends monsieur planchette
parler du déficit
et dire que en 4 qu'on ne peut rien
faire non on peut au moins se couper
d'une population à qui on a promis monts
et merveilles à kirumba bredeloup
moustache poulette
et puis bien tenir compte ces doléances
et faire en sorte que cette population
est soit épanoui au sein sa cité et bien
qu'un gardé la parole puisque vous
l'avez madame les 2000 à la rade de
stage puisque le tirage au sort vous a
désigné pour répondre à la première de
nos questions il y attendre le thème de
campagne qu'à saint pierre comme dans
toutes les communes et qui reviennent
incessamment qu'on est au contact de la
population qu'on entend on entend une
polémique sur le musée rénové non temps
une polémique sur le pylône de tdf qui
est allé à la cité qui a vu ce mariage
entre en gros la cathédrale et le et le
cimetière pour ceux qui qui visualise
ceux qui me connaissent pas on en avait
enfin saint denis
mais on entend aussi que st-pierre et le
mettra en place des grands projets aucun
saint-pierre devienne la capitale du
tourisme 2 martinique
et puis on est inquiet aussi sur
l'avenir de l'assaut des associations en
général mais là sont particuliers qui a
été un club de football et mérite du
nord caraïbes et qui bon place et a
laissé la céder sa place n'est ce pas
aller sans pression tient depuis quelque
temps donc beaucoup de sujets
d'inquiétude mais également peut-être
que des lions d'espagne
madame
la rade stache comment vous situez-vous
je parle même pas des camions qui
traversent sans arrêt comme on a entendu
de la microfinance a également ses
thèmes de campagne de réflexion comment
vous allez vous orientez votre campagne
parmi tous ces thèmes de campagne de
polémiques d'interrogation ou de lueur
d'espoir je vais tout simplement parler
en vérité à la population parce que la
population de saint pierre on a grand
besoin
il faut qu'on arrête les manipulations
les manipulations intellectuelle les
personnes les pieds rotin et pyrrhotine
que je salue en passant puisqu'on a
commencé directement sans les saluer
alors je sais à 8
si je salue pardon tous les martiniquais
mais aussi tous les pieds au teint
pilotine qui nous écoutent les piloter
envie de vivre dans deux lieux en dans
leur saint pierre envie de voir évoluer
cette ville vous avez parlé du musée
vous avez parlé d'un certain nombre de
choses je voudrais rebondir sur la
situation catastrophique de la ville de
saint pierre
monsieur le maire sortant clame haut et
fort partout que nous avons laissé un
déficit de 3 millions d'euros
j'ai un document ici que je vais vous
laisser qui a été signé le 23 avril par
son premier adjoint qui est monsieur
brand ben je salue c'est un monsieur
c'est un adjoint qui est décédé je salue
sa famille monsieur brand bon monsieur
grandement à signer le document le 23
avril un document qui est-il que l'inca
l'année 2015 pardon un document qui
stipule que le déficit de la ville était
de -129 1572 0,68 place une grosse
différence en 2014 et jeux légers le
document je vous le donne tout de suite
donc 130000 euros et non pas 4000
induits il est signé merci voilà 129
habitants nous ont remis le 16 72 sous
les yeux jean marc 129000 euros 572
euros 68 très exactement très exactement
donc la ville elle elle affiche ce
résultat ok
en 2014 ensuite en 2015
la ville affiche un excédent de 680
mille 415 euros 84
les wasps sont plus importantes
puisqu'elles sont de 11 millions 600 566
1807 euros 13 et les dépenses sont de 10
millions 886 1391 euros
29 ce qui donne un résultat un excédent
aura pas inonder les auditeurs et les
internautes accèdent maintenant terminée
mais un excédent le danger tout ce que
vous voulez démontrer à travers 180
milles 415 euros 84
c'est pour vous démontrer parce qu'on
entend aussi on entend le musée on
entend plein de choses mais il faut
aussi parler de la situation financière
de la ville parce qu on dira qu'on a
fait appel au privé parce qu'il n'y
avait pas d'argent telle ou telle chose
parce qu'il ya un pâle et fine hausse
alors que la situation en 2015 elle
était elle dégage un excédent
la situation s'est dégradée en 2016
parce que le maire a fait des choix
qu'il en prenne la responsabilité qui
conduit le en 2017
la chambre régionale des comptes a
épinglé son compte administratif donc
qu'on ne vienne pas raconter aux pieds
route et que kylie a pas d'argent pour
mener un certain nombre de projets à
bien et qu'on ne peut pas en quatre ans
faire aussi autonome de choses je
rebondis sur la musique la musique jeux
faut que les touristes
juste une précision pour ceux qui ne
sont pas pour les pilotes qui sont pas
pyrrhotine pierrotin d'ailleurs un des
pilotes thank you matinée n'ont pas
s'inspirer
saint pierraise comme ailleurs c'est une
parenthèse s'il s'agit du musée
volcanologique franck perrais donc pour
ceux qui ne savent pas de quoi de quel
musée nous parlons précisément durement
oui alors vous aurez le temps de
développer encore mai
la parole à un représentant de l'équipe
sortante
hervé planche est donc à entendre
ludmilla la rade aux tâches non quand
vous êtes arrivé aux affaires en 2015 il
n'y avait pas de déficit et votre
mauvaise gestion qui a mis en difficulté
la municipalité vous reprenez les propos
de nord je dis que c'est ce qu'elle a
dit il a donc fait réagir si vous
reprenez les beaucoup de mal à me non je
ne regarde pas je vais vous vous ne
m'aimez vous les reprenez voilà ce
qu'ils valent et bien j'en ai marre et
je vous demande à vous si vous êtes
d'accord avec ce qu'elle vient c'est
bien que je ne vais pas être d'accord
expliquez nous pourquoi ne vous a donné
qu'un seul document expliqué luu pour
d'accord parce que ce document qui date
du 23 avril n'est autre qu'un document
de notre peau maggia sur un compte
administratif qui était totalement faux
parce que c'est ce que nous rappelle la
chambre régionale des comptes dans son
rapport que nous a fait l'année dernière
nous disons que le déficit cumulé de la
ville de saint pierre n'est pas né de la
mandature mené depuis plus de deux mille
onze ans des mesures pour pouvoir pas en
compte
et puisqu'on parle de documents
officiels et que madame vous amène des
documents officiels
il va falloir mon mobilier qu'on arrête
de nous raconter n'importe quoi aux
pieds au point qu'on dise la vérité
parce que ces gens-là en 2001 se sont
fait élire sur un mensonge grossier
qu'il ne cesse de répéter actuellement
en disant qu'ils ont pris la ville de
saint pierre avec un déficit de 14
millions de francs
voilà leur peau de rechange régionale
des comptes que vous pouvez aller
vérifier sur le site de la cour des
comptes
voilà le rapport de la chambre régionale
des comptes sur un rapport a été fait en
2002 avec les chiffres et déficits et
des comptes publics
et si vous voyez ce document que la
ville de saint pierre entretien décembre
2001 avait un excédent de 93 à 1181
front c'est ça la vérité ça c'est un
document officiel de jean moulin des
comptes 2001 étrangères lors de
l'élection alors l équipe de raphaël
martin je précise pour ceux qui ne
savent où l'armée en ce moment et je
vous remercie monsieur vous pouvez aller
chercher également un bon document
s'asseoir d'accord ce document dont elle
parle de cul 23 avril et nous avons 2015
les quinze noms comme sommes arrivés il
fallait faire un état des lieux et nous
avons pris un cabinet indépendant pour
nous faire un audit non seulement 8
financier mais un audit organisationnel
c'est tout dit en avoir senti que nous
avions un déficit de 3,4 millions
d'euros c'est ça la réalité ils ne
veulent pas d'enfant c'est une vérité
elle fait mal mais il faut savoir à un
moment donné être mettre les choses au
clair
donc nous avons trouvé ce déficit il
nous a été conseillé de mesures que nous
avons dû prendre la première des mesures
que nous avons prises a précisé mathieu
blanchette vous parlez d'un déficit de 3
milliards et demi d'euros mais sur un
budget de combien parce que 3 milliards
le budget de l'époque est à peu près de
12 millions d'accord sur cette année on
l'a augmenté d'à peu près un peu plus
qu'un peu près 40%
il est de 18 millions celui de 18 19 mai
le budget de le le déficit que nous
avons trouvé ce qu'il fallait faire il
fallait à l'aumônerie prône des mesures
est la première des mesures et on
l'expliquait la population c'est que
tout le monde doit faire des efforts et
les premiers avons fait des efforts ce
sont les élus nous avons travaillé 36
mois sans toucher une seule indemnité et
ça ne nous a pas été imposée comme
certaines communes c'est nous qui avons
dès la campagne électorale avant d'être
élu ça a été une promesse de campagne
comme donc tenu nous avons dit non nous
avons nous allons donner l'exemple nous
savions qu'à 20 déficit mais la seule
chose que nous ne sommes pas c'étaient
leurs pleurs du déficit parce que nous
n'avons pas tout le pouvoir pour pouvoir
avoir alors eliane c'est ce tour entre
alors là cet échange de certificats a
pas de bonne gestion mais de mauvaise
gestion un chacun se renvoie la balle
analyse des deux et je vous dirais qu'en
2014 quand j'étais candidate
j'avais demandé certaines précisions
concernant la ville de saint piat est ce
que la ville de saint pierre à cette
époque-là avait demandé à la chambre à
la région au département
combien de dossiers étaient montés à la
région il n'avait pas beaucoup et je
peux vous dire que les comme dire à
monsieur planchette les trois quarts des
comptes administratifs et où il était
fou
je peux le dire clairement mais le
déficit toujours vive
je peux vous dire comment pouvez-vous me
dire que vous n'avez pas fait vous
n'avez pas fait de dossier de demande de
subvention vous n'avez pas fait
certaines demandes et que vous avez un
compte abondé avec et que vous que le
fonctionnement à cette époque là en 2000
quand je venais en 2014 c'était c'était
la volonté du maire la volonté du maire
à cette époque là c'était ils décidèrent
et on ne pouvait on pouvait que suivre
vous n'avez pas la possibilité au niveau
moi je parle de mon côté la partie
finance c'était un petit peu difficile
nous avons eu souvent des alertes parce
que je pense que monsieur l'ancienne
équipe
il était fâché avec le montage des
dossiers
monsieur martin donc chez martin dans le
montage des dossiers et surtout dans les
messages d'alert qui ont été données par
la cour des comptes et aussi par le
préfet je pense qu'il ne lisait pas et
centre de toutes les façons quand ' la
nouvelle équipe est arrivée en 2014 en
2015 et qu'ils à izon regarder l'ampleur
du déficit mais là quand vous analysez
le déficit parce qu'il faut l'analyser
vous sortez d'un excédent sous la
mandature de monsieur pierre charles
vous avez 14 ans pendant 14 ans une
autre kommandatur vous arrivez vous en
vous analysez ça ils ont pris un audit
mais après la cour des comptes a
réellement analyser ce déficit
et ils savent bien que peut-être que les
3 millions 8 que nous qu'ils ont trouvé
en arrivant n'était pas tout à fait de
3000 1 8 parce que la comptabilité à
cette époque était créé aléatoire à
saint pierre ça veut dire que beaucoup
d'écriture n'ont pas été à leur place
beaucoup de sol n'ont pas été vraiment
comptabilisés donc je pense qu'il y
avait un déficit structurel plus bas
plus plus bas oui je le veux je c'est à
dire nous on a on le dit nous a donné
quelque chose mais je pense que la cour
des comptes a repris au fur et à mesure
les années à la baisse mardi en 2018 il
y avait un déficit de 2004
à cette époque mais la seule chose qui
m'inquiétait aussi c'était pour la bonne
marche de la commune
s'il a la dette que nous avions au
fournisseur depuis 2014 peu avant nous
avions pendant 3 millions d'euros il
faut les remontées 6,3 millions d'euros
jusqu'à maintenant je pense qu on les
traîne encore parce que c'est encore
difficile de trouver alors voix c'est ce
que vous semblez trouver des
circonstances atténuantes à l'équipe
sortante donc attristera façon oui je
peux leur donner cette équipe parce
qu'ils ont travaillé sur ce dossier
la seule chose que je demande c'est de
mettre les choses à leur place
ça veut dire que dire qu'il ya trois
près de 3 millions il n'y avait pas tout
à fait 3 millions parce que quand vous
remettez en place toutes les écritures
je suppose que pour arriver à maintenant
un million et quelques de déficit mais
né d'un milieu quelqu'un en une année
vous ne leur en vendent et par ludmilla
la radio ce stage va évidemment vouloir
répondre c'est ça mais mais ce que vous
dites c'est que il faut arrêter
peut-être de prendre ça comme maintenant
comme prétexte pour l'équipe sortante et
si on comprend à demi mot ce que voulait
dire diane sesto ce n'est pas ce qui
vous permet c'est à dire que quand vous
trouvez un déficit aussi important
vous n'avez plus de marge de manoeuvre
vous pouviez à cette époque là je vais
vous dire en 2014 il était presque
question qu'on fasse un plan coca pour
saint-pierre ça veut dire au lieu d'être
sous tutelle on aurait pu le plan coca
mais le plan coca n'ayant pas toutes les
factures vous ne pouvez pas y aller
donc on était aide technique et
financière que l'état a commis contre
les cas visés par le préfet à ce moment
là c'était presque à cette époque là
c'est à ce niveau là le je pense que
l'équipe en à cette nouvelle équipe est
arrivée elle a certainement certaines
demandes et un certain délai ce qui leur
a permis de travail et de remettre les
choses à leur place
ludmila la radio stage je j'entends tout
ça
et je vous dis vraiment je suis pas
étonné de la des propos de madame c
store parce que quand on sait qu'en 2015
madame c'est ce taux avait appelé à
voter pour l'équipe de monsieur la fin
et que cette année encore on ne sait pas
de qui le ppm va soutenir si c'est
madame c'est aussi c'est monsieur
raphaël à bien ce projet moi ce que je
dis je m'adresse aux pierrotin je suis
un petit peu surprise d'entendre madame
c est odieux qu'il n'y a pas eu de
réalisation je vous ai emmené tout
toutes nos réalisations d'accord de 2001
à 2004 aux tout un panel de choses vous
verrez monsieur carouge feuilletée je
vous ai emmené ce document parce que
j'en ai assez d'entendre du n'importe
quoi nous sommes arrivés aux affaires
avec une une ville qui justement au
lendemain une ville qui n'est pas t'es
pas construite du tout une ville qui
était où il y avait une équipe en place
s'unir pour bâtir alors c'est vraiment
du n'importe quoi sur bourgoin battu
alors que la ville elle était dans un
état d'abandon manifeste pas
d'affrontement pas de place bertin là où
victor hugo c'est la route principale en
est a vraiment vraiment piteuse état
avec des écoles vraiment en état de
délabrement pas de d'ordinateurs dans
les classes pour les enfants alors qu'on
est à cette époque où toutes les
établissements de la martinique sont
dotés d'ordinateurs eveno petit pierrot
tu n avais pas d'ordinateur pas de halo
quand nous sommes arrivés aux affaires
non seulement il fallait préparer la
ville à recevoir le santonnier de
l'éruption de la montagne pelée où les
yeux et est vraiment tourné sur saint
pierre
il fallait construire cette ville nous
avons fait l'affrontement la place
berthet et pour ça il fallait solliciter
puisque nous avons trouvé un déficit
important
non me le permettez que je continue
comme vous n'avez pas reçu non jamais je
n'ai jamais dit madame 16
alors nous avons comme les chênes a été
battue au 2e rang de 15 me vois pas
revenir de londres quoi voir notre quoi
voix au premier tour et un écart de 100
voix au deuxième tour
donc on disait que kimi à vernier donc
je voulais rappeler aux pierrotin le soc
nautique la cathédrale qui est entré
dans le dans le patrimoine de la ville
alors qu'il a été rétrocédé à la ville
depuis 1949 la sortie l'hôpital
c'est le leur ne voulais pas finir
simenon mais vous défendez la
médiathèque mais vous n'aurez aucune
offre pour répondre sur le musée
ludmilla l'arradoy et vous jeunesse vous
utilisez je n'aime pas entendre que nous
avons gagné un prix mais vous avez on a
travaillé il avait dit je vais pas faire
le château des comtes 10 a traité 1 mais
besançon alors vous ne vous avez donné
des exemples donc démission alors
justement jean polémique sur le musée le
musée volcanologique franck perrais qui
est située sur les hauteurs de saint
pierre et qui contient les vestiges de
la catastrophe de 1900 du musée qui
existe qui a été qui est tombé en
désuétude quasiment et qui a été
plusieurs fois rénové réhabiliter mais
finalement la municipalité actuelle a
décidé de passer à la vitesse supérieure
en confiant à une entreprise privée
une la culture abandons sont n'a pas
cités sont une filiale de la fondation
bernard ayotte la gestion durant cet
homme s'amusait ce qui a créé de
l'incompréhension de la frustration et
beaucoup de débats depuis un an et demi
que cette décision était prise et qui
arrivait donc être mises en oeuvre
décembre dernier il ya seulement deux
mois et donc
justement votre groupe madame les
admirals à la rade estime qu' il y a dix
ans d écriture de documents qu'il n'en
est pas réellement l'historique de cette
décision et vous soupçonnez le maire
d'avoir pour fait son choix avant même
les procédures légales d'appel d'offres
de mise en concurrence et que c'était
excitant comme s'il voulait favoriser
je crois que madame stockées sur ce
registre me semble-t-il peut-être madame
oui mais la radio stage aussi mais je
crois que c'est vous qui je vous dis
animer la campagne avec ça
la première question qui m'est venue
quand j'ai appris comment cet effet j'ai
demandé qui était en appel d'offres
c'est la première question mais j'étais
je vais souvent conseil municipal donc
en mois d'avril j'ai bien entendu que la
fondation clément allait se porter pour
pouvoir faire les travaux j'ai trouvé ça
très bien sauf que au début du mois deux
points mais août j'entends que ya une
association qui s'appelle culture à bam
qu'est le porteur de projet dit accord
et sauf que cultura bam et croyez au
mois d'octobre qui était en appelle
d'autres
bon
à hilla et ifs un conseil municipal pour
valider le mois d'après jean corman
novembre et ensuite les travaux ont
commencé
la seule interrogation que j'ai pour moi
juste en tant que citoyenne de
saint-pierre
c'est la rapidité c'est que à peine
déposé le permis de construire de lever
le 21 décembre le 2 janvier ça avait
commencé
la seule chose que je demande c'est en
matière d'équité c'est que si ça a pu
être fait par une entreprise comme ça
est ce qu'un autre une autre association
qui ont eu le même circuit
bénéficieraient de cette même façon de
fonctionner pour moi ça ferait
jurisprudence c'est tout voilà pour le
reste le musée qui soit rénové qui sont
à rénover par une délégation de service
public
je trouve que c'est c'était une solution
là le maire nous a fait comprendre que
le musée vraiment ils tombaient si
c'était une urgence
personnellement je pense qu'avec
d'autres urgences mais bon chaque
personne humaine sékouba est ce que les
la population saint pierre frick en
s'amuser
je pense je suis pas sûr nous pouvons
demander son analyse avec la chatte qui
représente ici de brossard entendent
mondiaux parisiens s'ils fréquentent à
tour eiffel il ya dit il y à des
mouvements qui sont destinés à à une
exploitation touristique qui apporte un
éclat une région à une ville
donc soyons sérieux le musée de saint
pierre ou peut être un atout important
non seulement pleuvent la politique
touristique de la ville mais également
pour la martinique
nous avons déjà répondu largement sur ce
problème du musée déjà ce ne sont pas
des associations se sont dits fondation
donc si la fondation clément qui a
répondu à cet appel d'offres en avril
il dansait dans son dossier de
candidature
il a fait mention de la création d'une
entité de la fondation clément qui
s'appelle culture à bam qui portera le
projet a le 17 décembre nous avons fait
un conseil municipal qui a hâte qu'il y
ait ce marché le 21 décembre par l'ong
qui a inscrit dieu ce marché à cultura
bam et donc à la fondation clément donc
tout a été fait dans la légalité
maintenant il ya des procédures pour
contrer ce genre de propos ou de
commander le procédé il y à qu'a porté
plainte
et puis on verra et la loi la
jurisprudence fra fra loi ou comme
dirait madame madame sesto il faut que
nous avancions ce musée nous avions
signé une convention groupement de
commandes avec la région
quand elle était dirigée par six sièges
de chimie en mai 2015 tout de suite
après notre arrivée pour qu' il soit
rénové entièrement par la région en
tunique ça n'a pas été une priorité d'un
septième il nous fallait trouver une
solution parce que ceux qui parlent du
main par exemple ce musée quand nous
l'avons trouvé il n'y avait que deux
employés qui travaillaient 365 jours par
an dans ce musée ou deux climatiseurs
sur quatre ne fonctionnait pas les
les stations l'équipe n'était plus aux
normes d'accord un moment donné il faut
qu'on prenne les choses voilà alors
qu'on se dise on y va faute faute du du
financement de la subvention de la ctn
que vous attendiez de l'aide je sais pas
si c'est vraiment une subvention mais
enfin où demandiez en compte un évident
si c'est très dur c'est une procédure
qui s'appelle un groupement de commande
qui permet à une collectivité de
financer entièrement un bâtiment où une
action d'une autre collectivité donc le
deuxième dossier dit vous a été pour
ainsi dire gelé un petit peu à la jolie
était gelée et donc c'est pour ça que
vous vous êtes tourné vers ce
partenariat il nous fait public privé en
vous adressant donc au groupe bernard
alioth et à sa fondation enfin la
fondation clément de 2gb faut arrêter de
dire que la fondation c'est la fondation
clément et s'adressaient pas la
fondation clément samedi c'est à tout le
monde parce que c'était une délégation
de ces aides publiques donc il y avait
un appel d'offres et seule la fondation
il a répondu si c'est pas notre foi s'il
ya qu une seule personne qui arrive dans
la fondation clément est lié au groupe
bernard hayot quand même c'est une
fondation qui a été créée dernière elle
est y pas eu les pattes une ce n'est pas
une activité du groupe b turnberry aux
phobies n'a fait qu est ce que c'est
qu'une fenêtre alors ludmilla la radio
stache jeu nuit je n'ai rien contre la
réhabilitation du musée puisque nous
avions justement engagé nous étions
engagés à les novae ce musée et nous
étions pourparlers avec le conseil
régional de l'époque au faire en sorte
que ce musée qui ne répondaient pas aux
normes non plus
soit réhabilité mais la manière dont ça
s'est passé à l'insu et au vu des pieds
au thé dansant concertation sans
vraiment impliquer les piloter leur
informer de cette délégation de service
public qui a été prise le 1er août alors
que cultura bam a été déclaré le 3
octobre 2018 journal officiel est paru
le 13 octobre 2018
moi je trouve que ce sont pas des
manières de faire pour une équipe qui se
dit respectueux des règles et des lois
de la république et je vous rappelle que
la chambre régionale des comptes le
rappelle la mise
en concurrence systématique avant tout
commandes de biens et de prestations de
service a placé la sas et la chambre
régionale qui le dit d'accord une
succession de transport il aussi dans le
domaine gestionnaire a enfourché
distance ici parce qu'il faut lire plus
nous allons poursuivre me défoule du ce
qu'elle dit madame je peux laisser ils
disent que dans cette chapelle ainsi le
début 2011
c'est pas je veux rappeler aux plus
hautes que ce n'est pas christian afin
qu'ils aient été condamnés pour délits
favoritisme et 3000 euros damende de ne
pas les respecter les marchés publics
c'est par christian à quoi fait
référence à la condamnation de monsieur
raphaël martin parce qu'il n'a pas
respecté le code des marchés publics
dans la sphère vos nouvelles
c'est de ça dont il s'agit c'est pas le
skc la chambre régionale de nous nous
nous explique que depuis 2011
les le code des marchés publics n'a pas
été respecté c'est ce qu'ils sont connus
il ne parle pas du musée là dedans
en vous pour arrêter de dieu n'est
pourtant pas en voudra le développement
chez lisa entièrement et la gestion de
ce rapport tout d'abord les nouveaux
j'aurais voulu elle est située à nouveau
oui les nouveaux et jeu on a toujours
voté le compte administratif en
concordance avec le compte du percepteur
donc on n'a jamais eu de problème il n'y
a pas de plaintes de déposées jusqu'à
maintenant on peut parler parvenons
revenons sur halo musée donc vous vous
trouvez que le procédé n'a pas été
toujours respectueux et dans les règles
de votre avis votre opinion donc
ludmilla la rade d'eustache alors
justement parlons organiser la mairie en
place considérant que c'est un élément
central pas le seul mais un élément sûr
on y verrait sa vision quant à cette
vision du développement du tourisme de
l'activité touristique de l'animation
touristique pour faire de ces pierres la
capitale du tourisme de martinique parce
que saint-raphaël occasions explique à
plusieurs reprises saint pierre va
n'appartient pas au pire haute et
saint-pierre à part entière à la
martinique et il s'agit pour lui je
pressens je reprends ses propres sons
néologisme il s'agit de martinique anisé
saint pierre pour faire en sorte que
toute la population soient fiers et soit
informé de ce cas et et saint pierre de
ce qu'elle peut être aujourd'hui
alors eric chenneveau qui va présenter
crise sur lafarge disco boys les
éclaircissements sachant que l'amérique
comme vous le dites n'a pas beaucoup de
moyens financiers pour impulser une
politique touristique qui sont des
frontières de la ville
je vais expliquer vous de vous expliquer
notre que notre philosophie là dessus
saint pierre est une ville qui concentre
plus de quinze monuments historiques
ces monuments historiques il faut que
nous fassions comprennent non seulement
aux habitants du nord aux habitants de
la martinique mais aussi au niveau
national que ces monuments ne sont pas
la propriété uniquement dépiauter que ce
ne sont pas ce n'est pas seulement au
pays hôte et de les entretenir
c'est la patrie jasmin a forcé ou cela
que nous recherchons des financements
que ce soit à travers cap nau que ce
soit à travers la 7e que ce soit avec
l'état et peut-être même aussi au niveau
de l'euro pour nous aider à entretenir
pour que les impôts des pires outils
servent à être utilisé pour les piloter
dans notre tient de leur vie quotidienne
dans leur cadre de vie comme n'importe
quelle commune parce que vous voyez
n'importe quelle commune de martinique
il n'y a pas autant de monuments
historiques à entretenir et ça coûte
très cher donc notre philosophie c'est
que les six mouvements historiques ils
ont fait l'histoire de ses clients ils
ont fait l'histoire du nord de
l'allemagne
ils ont fait l'histoire de la martinique
et ils ont également fait l'histoire de
france parce que beaucoup de ponts
français sont nés et ont vécu parce que
la marchandise participiez à nantes
bordeaux c'est par la rochelle this ont
existé ont été créés par ce qu'elle veut
ce fameux marche i tunes qui est une
période de notre de notre histoire mais
ces villes là aussi orientées s'en vont
faire montrer au reste du monde que ces
mouvements là il ce n'est pas seulement
le lait pour les pilotins qui doivent
les entretiens est ce que ce discours
est
ancien compris par la population et 5e
c'est ce que nous essayons de faire et
c'est ce que nous allons faire à travers
ce qu'on appelle le siaap
le centre d'interprétation de
l'architecturé du patrimoine non une des
premières missions est de faire prendre
conscience aux pires août 1 de la valeur
de leur patrimoine est bien de cet os
quel est votre projet cas une
proposition vous avez pour le
développement un meilleur développement
genre touristique de saint pierre et
donc par extension gens du nord n'est
d'avoir jamais une ville très atypique
très demandés tout le reste mais à saint
pierre il n'y a pas que des monuments
il y a une population et cette
population je pense qu'elle a été
oubliée depuis très longtemps et elle a
certes un duel à certains besoins
cette population qui vit justement
jusqu'à maintenant ça fait je dirais des
décennies que nous avons un problème
avec les carrières à cause des camions
ce flux qui est de plus en plus intense
qui impacte toute la population fera un
frein pour un développement bon
développement touristique oui c'est vrai
c'est un très grand frein parce que la
pop
il suffit que l'un de ses camions
s'arrête vous avez bloqué jusqu au
prêcheur houzel gauche jusqu'aux korber
donc les toiles à la circulation est
très difficile
non seulement elle est difficile mais le
flux de ses camions l'impact que sur les
les bâtiments pas que les bâtiments de
proximité mais les maisons de ces
personnes et là il faudrait avoir un
sérieux plan marshall pour pouvoir aider
ces personnes parce que tout le monde ne
peut pas se permettre de réparer sa
maison mais ça fait des dizaines
d'années coincé là jusqu'à maintenant ça
va mieux qu'il ya des lobby très
puissant qui empêche que d'autres
solutions envisagées vont transporter le
matériau de sainte-philomène au fond
qu'à nos villes jusqu à fort de france
on avait on avait une seule solution
pour voir les verts et six mois oui mais
même si vous avez les lobbys mais les
lobbys vous pouvez aussi les contourner
on avait une seule solution qu'on
pouvait les avoir
les trois maires précédents n'ont pas
réussi à contourner ce lobby comme ce
soit monsieur un charme c'est parti
aujourd'hui tu fais là vous rendez vous
vous rappelez quand on a eu la halle
ou des liens trouve exacte à ce moment
là on a arrêté la circulation des
camions au lieu de les arrêter pendant
une semaine il fallait le faire pendant
un mois jusqu'à ce qu'on ait terminé je
vous assure que les lobbies ou étouffer
une solution est peut-être que la
situation des banques au et mélangez
rapidement
c'est tout ce que je peux vous dire
l'aïe pour vous il ya un manque de
volonté politique qui a été aussi
prolongé par l'équipe sortante
non mais je pense que c'est dans ces
subventions que je pose tout le monde
subit encore parce que bon les lobbys
sont quand même assez puissant à bon
temps quand on fait les choses comme
elles sont convenues que c'est pas c'est
pas facile
bon mais moi je vais passer c'est pas
une raison peut-être pour ça
complètement mais non non moi je moi je
demande justement parce que moi si je me
porte candidate c'est justement parce
que la première chose qu'il faudrait une
des premières des travaux ce serait de
réunir tout le monde d'avoir une grande
discussion à ce sujet vous savoir la
faisabilité de façon à ce qu'elles ont
une meilleure fluidité et un à
l'aménagement du territoire alors soit
enfant tient donc lui 2001 la radio ce
stage c'est bien de sesto envoie tout le
monde un peu dos à dos dans cette
affaire là donc l'équipe qui a précédé
celle de monsieur rafa vous n'avez pas
réussi non plus à faire en sorte que les
camions ne passent plus par là enfin par
le centre bourg de saint pierre jette
contournement de la ville qui a été pas
encore l'équipe actuelle qui a été un
bain qu'on a laissé qui est tombé à
l'eau parce qu'on a laissé entendre aux
gens que qu'on allait déplacer leur
maison et finalement on a laissé tomber
donc si on doit prendre ce projet il
faudrait repartir convaincre les gens
peut-être qu'il ya des personnes qui
sont décédées entre comme vous voulez
roissy voulait relancer ce projet si
vous êtes élu on va étudier la loi
étudié la demande qui a étudié la
demande des cantons gardent ainsi
l'appel - élite et du transport par
branches qui avait déjà été expérimentée
donc ce sera on prendra le temps mais
vous savez bien que les vendeurs de
camions que les vendeurs de pièces
détachées de camions que les vendeurs de
matériaux de construction ne sont pas
trop d'accord avec nous
mais ce ne sont pas des pierrotin nous
le savons c'est manqué on va il va
falloir bien trouver une solution et met
tout le monde autour de la table pour
trouver vraiment cette solution pour
saint pierre
eh bien on arrive alors vous les aviez
quand même si elle est née sur les
carrières se sont nés en une minute
trente s'il vous plaît justement rappelé
que 60 % des matériaux de construction
qui construisent le reste de la
martinique sont dits trois carrières de
saint pierre ça c'est une première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que il y a deux
aspects effectivement en 2008 il ya eu
une expérimentation de transport par
barge qui montrait qu'une barge de 20
mille tonnes pouvait réduire de 35%
le flux de camions de sueur sur le toit
concernant cette comptable qui coûterait
environ entre 60 et 70 millions
les 250 camions qui passent chaque jour
à saint pierre il passe aussi au carbet
il dépasse aussi à bellefontaine et
passent aussi à case-pilote centre avait
déjà falloir vous dois dû faire une
requête dans chacune de ces villes
il suffisait simplement et c'est une
volonté effectivement politique dont
nous n'avons pas la charge puisque c'est
pas les villes qui ont la charge du
transport il suffisait de ne pas monter
de ne pas monter les uns contre les
autres mais de mettre une convergence de
rassembler tout le monde
les carrières les les chauffeurs de
camion les collectifs de population et
avril d'éprouver les solutions erp
blanche est votre conception à vous
votre équipe au maire dans cette affaire
c'est quoi l'intérêt général doit primer
sur l'intérêt économique
inversement les niveaux c'est l'intérêt
économique et il doit primer sur
l'intérêt général les deux doivent
doivent pas parce que ça général pour
vous pas en cause dans cette affaire
parce que ce que veulent les chauffeurs
de camions ne sont pas contre le fait du
transport bas en revanche il veut
simplement être aussi actionnaire d'une
entreprise qui va jouer ses manches 6
tout ce qu'ils demandent parce que ce
chauffeur de camion pilot study à 3
heures du matin pour être à saint-pierre
à 5 heures qui sont de rivière-pilote il
et aubigny me restait de sang il
ramenait sur les chantiers parce que la
barge va déposer le sommes à la pointe
des seins comme son indice est ainsi
fait il faut les ramener sur les
chantiers donc ce transport ne va pas
disparaître simplement si les
actionnaires si il y à une compensation
et puis s'il ya aussi une compensation
de la ctm pouvoir compagne et ce qu'ils
y font la roche de la route et n'a
compris vos méthodes
gagnant du gagnant gagnant c'est ça la
solution voilà c'est l'heure des
conclusions et est arrivé donc on
rappelle que c'est vous monsieur
planchette qui allait donc terminer cet
exercice
on commence par vous ludmilla lara
d'eustache pour une minute de conclusion
donc vous adresser directement aux
électrices et électeurs de saint pierre
alors j'invite les pierrotin pied
routine s quoi vigilant you bad boys
lomu sache pour les temps 2015 et les
pas question qu'on recommence la même
chose en 2020 vous avez une femme
engagée sur le terrain puisque je pense
que pour être pour faire de la politique
il faut aimer les gens
il faut être proche proche de la
population et moi je le suis je vous
demande de me faire confiance
mon équipe et moi pour mener à bien les
affaires de cette ville je vous demande
de dire de tourner le dos à tous ces
manipulateurs intellectuelle à tous ces
mensonges et de venir écouter nos
réunions de quartier pour avoir nos
informations les bonnes informations
voilà c'est à votre tour eu lieu en face
tour qui retient piétine je suis
candidate à nouveau pour pouvoir briguer
les la commune de saint pierre dans la
mesure où je pense que maintenant j'ai
tout le temps et le temps nécessaire
pour pouvoir m'occuper de vous surtout
que moi ma mon projet c'est surtout de
m'occuper de la population et des
associations de voir la faisabilité de
la 2e cadre de vie qui pourrait
intéresser tous les to les pierrotin
surtout que depuis quelques temps que
nous sommes très visitée par des
touristes aussi qu'ils puissent
bénéficier d'une certaine de certains
cadres de vie concernant les les
affaires et tout le reste cher sachant
que cette pièce est une ville avec
énormément de bâtiments à rénover mais
surtout moi je voudrais commencer par
une nouvelle que cette population et
surtout leur dire de revenir dans le
centre est de ne pas aller à l'extérieur
il te faudrait comme avec mon équipe que
nous travaillons hâte que nous puissions
remettre toute cette population
repeupler le centre pour lui redonner
vie et à son agent nous vous disons le
15 mars que nous serons là
et que nous allons être là pour pouvoir
défendre vos intérêts merci et enfin
monsieur blanchette tréport la
conclusion de cette lecture il est
respecté vous avez vu un petit peu ce
qui s'est passé pendant ces cinq
dernières années nous avait vus à
l'oeuvre vous n'avez vu travailler vous
ne l'avez vu vous apporter un meilleur
cadre de vie un peu de cohésion dans
cette dans cette ville nous avons vous
avez le choix entre le 3-3 listé trois
slogans et moi je pense que les trois
second se valent
parce que pour bien agir pou saint
pierre ou que les générations soient
fiers de ce que nous ait choisis comme
comme politique pour la ville la
meilleure façon de le prouver c'est de
faire gagner saint piat et de mettre le
bulletin pour tourner christian a failli
dualiste fergani cpa nous comptons sur
vous nous sommes avec vous nous
travaillons pour merci voilà avant de
céder la parole à jean-marc pour
conclure et annoncer les prochains
rendez vous je dois rappeler j'ai fait
référence à la baie de fort-de-france
par rapport à la baie de saint pierre la
rade de saint pierre mais le nom c'est
la baie des flamands c'est une bête qui
touche plusieurs communes je le rappelle
non mais c'est vrai communément on
l'appelle baie de fort-de-france
mais c'est la baie des flamands donc qui
qui touchent aussi bien du cos que le
lamantin ou où les trois il est aussi
par exemple remarquer pascal arabe de
ces pierres est quand même plus belle
plus agréable l'espagne et elle ne
touche que la ville de saint-pierre de
carbeo prêcheur bon ben voilà donc elle
est aussi multi communal voilà c'est
ainsi que se termine cette émission
réalisée aujourd'hui par eddy le curieux
le promener une étrange était assurée
par michel joseph ce débat était
organisé avec la participation d'alain
niveau 8
vous pouvez retrouver sur notre site
internet jusqu'à toute la campagne
jusqu'à l'avant-veille du scrutin
le prochain débat en radio sur internet
sera ce lundi
lundi 3 février comme tous les lundis
avec les candidats de rivière-pilote
mardi car le lendemain ce sera enterrée
avec les candidats de marigot que nous
avons eu l'occasion de recevoir ici même
en radio vendredi dernier et puis
vendredi prochain 7
février oui ça va vite fait c'est
mouillé le débat radio à nouveau avec le
candidat 200 tonnes voilà madame
monsieur mes ainsi à bientôt
merci à vous merci à vous
[Musique]